-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
[ Cheering and applause ]
This is very exciting --
last night was our first night
with an audience.
This is the exact same group
of people.
They refused to leave.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to the news,
everybody.
Dr. Anthony Fauci said,
in an interview on Sunday,
that it's safe for Americans
to go trick-or-treating
this year on Halloween.
Though, remember, you may get
something worse than COVID.
[ Laughter and applause ]
According to a new poll,
Americans are losing trust
in President Biden's ability
to handle
the coronavirus pandemic.
Really?
Who's handling it well?
[ Laughter ]
We're all losing it.
"The Brady Bunch"
came on the other day
and I thought it was
a Zoom meeting.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Can't wait to hear
Cindy's thoughts on marketing.
I don't trust anyone
who's handling it well.
When I'm at ShopRite and there's
an old guy with no mask on
just smiling
and touching all the cans,
whistling a happy tune,
I don't think,
"Oh, I wish he was in charge."
[ Laughter ]
The State Department
inspector general
is reportedly investigating
several instances
of misappropriated gifts
from foreign governments
during the Trump administration,
including a missing $5,800
bottle of Japanese whiskey
and I found it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Right there.
It was --
It was a bottle of whiskey
who wished
it was a real man.
[ Laughter ]
But he wished it
on a monkey paw.
[ Laughter ]
Arizona Senator Kyrsten Sinema
yesterday attended
the Boston Marathon,
but did not run the race,
due to a foot injury,
but did manage to get in the way
of the people handing stuff out.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
The Taliban --
The Taliban!
[ Cheer and laughter ]
[ As Trump ] The Taliban,
we love the Taliban.
[ Laughter ]
The Taliban has reportedly
instructed its religious police
to be more moderate,
which means even the Taliban
passed police reform
before we did.
[ Laughter, oohs,
and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
Pope Francis --
Pope Francis over the weekend
launched a two-year initiative
to consult every Catholic parish
around the world
about the future of the Church.
And this is cool --
because of how often
they get moved around,
a lot of priests are going
to meet him twice.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
That's cool, alright.
Alright.
I'd like to point out --
super fair hit.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Super fair hit.
LEGO announced yesterday
that it will remove
all gender stereotypes
from its toys,
though there will still be
some gender stereotypes
when you step on one.
"Son of a bitch!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
DC Comics announced yesterday
that the new Superman character
will come out as bisexual.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Come on, it's 2021.
The crazy part is that there are
still Superman comics.
You see, kids,
he's a reporter at a newspaper.
"He's a what at a what?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
He changes in a telephone booth.
"What are you talking about?
[ Laughter and applause ]
What are these things?"
McDonald's is offering
free breakfast meals this week
to teachers and support staff,
giving teachers a chance
to do what they love most --
eat in their car.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A man in England recently
visited 51 bars in 24 hours,
in an attempt to set
a Guinness World Record.
The record was for most COVID.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
firefighters in Florida
recently rescued a kitten
that was stuck in the inner
workings of a Tesla.
Said the Tesla's owner,
"I have a Tesla."
[ Laughter and applause ]